what is your advice for like absolutely
zero to roof over your head the quickest
way to go from $20 to 10,000 I genuinely
believe is genuinely people of the
Universe I bring to you Gary
V what's up Universe yeah dude I decided
to go woke are you woke
no not not even but uh but ladies and
gentlemen and it occurred to me you know
leave some people out and while I don't
want to be woke I do want to include
absolutely everybody I love that so so
that's why you're doubling down on
Universe yeah yeah yeah everybody in the
universe yeah all shapes and Si yeah all
you little [__] like uh oh steo is
woke like suck a fart out of my butthole
and chill out like uh we're we're light
we're easy we're having a good time and
this is Gary V good to meet you pleasure
brother real pleasure me you honestly
you're a real legend thank you for
having me you guys are about the same
age yeah how old are you I'm 49 yeah I
just turned 48 and you 46 Jesus Christ
40 40 sorry it's a lot of gray you look
phenomenal if I now that I've now that
you react that way and I'm looking
closer to the skin I might have went 38
but if if the gray was black you're 38
no I know I'm gr [__] yeah of course
it's just harder to hear that I I I met
up with Simon Eddie at the at the
wedding and uh he's like are you 50 now
I'm like [__] 50 now it's just it's
normal human behavior the gray over
indexes it and but the cool part is
you're fully in control like you're you
mean I have my hair well yes which is
amazing I think what saying is you're in
control it's not too late to to move
your
body yeah it's not too late to put down
the pasta I know I bet you equally you
get good compliments on the Silver Fox
thing yeah well yeah so you're just I'm
it's the choice of going bald or gray
I'd rather go gray a
th% 100% the question is do you want to
color it green no black no and then
you're F enoy I enjoy going Silver Fox
but you're going to get some 44s instead
of 38s for sure sometimes even yeah
sometimes whoever that which is crazy
cuz the face is too baby but that's
nothing 44 and 38 same [__] yeah I'm at
the age where like uh people are
starting to like Mis guess my age and
I'm like oh [__] it's happening I'm
getting older well the worst part was
when you you know we're all going
through this you're still a youngster
like that flip where like you know like
I me and a lot of my friends were
babyfaced so when we were at 26 you'd go
to Vegas and you get card you be like
yeah you still got it all of a sudden
you're like 34 and you're like you 40
like what just happened why did I just
age 20 years in a seven-year window yeah
age is undefeated fellas that's correct
man and and I I could stand to uh put
down some food and and move my body
around a little bit too I'm oh I got it
I think at 40 it it it becomes more of a
health issue than like a vanity issue
yeah you know I I was at Dr Drew's house
today how that and I I love Dr Drew and
I think we we should get him back on but
but that's another conversation for
another time and uh with with Gary ve
not
um candidly yes Gary you're you're so uh
specialized in in uh business being an
entrepreneur financial success and and
we've always enjoyed speaking with our
guests about like what what their
various revenue streams you know like
love to hear guest top three revenue
streams without being invasive about
numbers but uh but you want me to answer
or
yeah
never so I think I think I operate and
invest and so what I mean by that is I
actively am always running a company
from you know from my childhood from
being 22 to 34 I did that from my dad's
liquor store those were not super
successful Financial years because I was
building the company for him and we were
an immigrant family and you don't get
paid a lot but it was epic and one of my
Great accomplishments so when I say I
operate and I invest right now I'm the
CEO of a company called Vayner at
Vayner media is the big company in that
I love this yeah a modern-day
Communications company so basically
Madmen 2023 my company does the
marketing for companies like Pepsi and
Chase and all these Fanatics and all
these big Brands and we do different
[__] some people we do all the social
media content some people we do the
Super Bowl commercial we killed Mr
Peanut oh wow we were the agency that
worked on Planters when we killed Mr P
during the Super it's an ad agency but
it's 2024 version almost every client we
work with we're like do you understand
how important it is to do social media
right you know that kind of I mean look
this is actually very meta liquid death
yeah started by Mike the job he had
while he was building liquid death was
at Vayner media in La wow sent me an
emails like I'm ready to do my own thing
do you want to invest I'm like yeah I
wanted to support him he's a good dude I
was like here's a couple bucks I'm going
to make a [__] fortune on it because
he's a beast and he built liquid death
he Mike cesio is a very very impressive
guy
of liquid that's right and literally the
job the second before he was the CEO of
liquid death he was a creative director
at Vayner media no kidding yeah he is
absolutely a creative have you heard of
hot sauce for your butthole do you want
this to explode and you want me to help
you out make yeah honestly no [__]
honestly no [__] it would be great
enjoyment whether right after this
podcast and we got a couple minutes or
let's get on Zoom the joy I would have
to tell you to do six or seven different
things to quadruple the [__] out of this
business would be a great pleasure of
mine you don't have to say that twice
yeah happy to do it so anyway uh I don't
want to be longwinded I'm always driving
something Vayner media the other thing I
do is vriends which is like my Pokemon
meets uh Marvel meets Sesame Street an
intellectual property nfts trading cards
apparel um coming out with animation uh
here you can see it so be friends is
really exciting for me you guys are
quite creative so you can imagine how
exciting this is for me like literally
as a baseball card collectible comic
book kid I can't believe I actually have
like I can go on eBay right now and go
to complete it actually you guys are
doing this here if you go on eBay and go
to completed items like it's crazy to me
if you type in V friend now I saw you
make a post about your V friends and you
said that you were going to make it as
big as Pokemon that's right that might
let me let me clar like and even
sometimes I need to do a better job C
for the next 50 years I'd like to make
it as yep keep scrolling you're good
whoever this is Beast there it is
completed and sold hit them both there
you go look this is [__] like I just got
to say as someone who like has been on
eBay since 1998 and just loves garage
selling and finding [__] and buying [__]
and pop cultures why I [__] with you
heavy like looking at this like blows my
I [__] Drew these things three years
ago and now it's like a full pledge real
thing okay we're looking at trading
cards at the moment trading cards that
sold on eBay um and which is distinctly
different from nfts you know what's
funny I I think wildly not different but
I get where you're going I understand
fible and non-fungible very smart well
nft is strictly digital correct correct
yeah okay I I was telling my dad yes
that that like My Philosophy or my
understanding of nfts that it's like
here like anybody that wants to bring it
up on the internet technically can have
it but the person who uh who buys the
nft actually owns it that's right I said
Dad this is like uh tell telling a woman
you know yeah like any woman in the
world can have my wiener
but my we is actually
yours okay that makes so much more sense
that was how you got your dad to
understand well yeah just like that's my
way of saying anybody can have it but
like one person's supposed to like have
ownership of it just sounds like so
anyway these are the two companies I run
I also do you know so let's talk about
it every is different because I do a lot
of investing so obviously one day liquid
death will sell to Pepsi or Coke and
I'll get a check for that investment
yeah do you think that's G to
happen are you an investor yeah nice uh
I I don't know uh I I'm sure at this
point anybody with you know between that
and Prime energy drink there's some big
beverages running around there that are
independent that I'm sure the Cokes and
the Pepsis and the biggest companies are
looking at I think next two three year
you'll see more and more m&a activity
but the place I make my most dollars is
being the CEO of VOR media it's a 2,000
person $300 million plus business I'm
the founder operator so that's that
world that's in Vader X um this I mean
speaking is big for me stebo okay good
yeah I'm a I'm a I'm a pretty
substantial public speaker and like my
fee is pretty bananas and if when I
we're getting close enough to the end of
the year that may be the second biggest
of my Revenue so you book your um your
speaking engagements which would be
considered a personal appearance that's
right uh with through an agent so I was
with ca for a long time and then 5 years
ago I started my own speaking bureau
Vayner speakers W so if you're looking
to make you know I can make you some
money on the sauce I can make you some
money on the speaking there you go yeah
you have a story this is turning out to
be a really good you no you know I'm I'm
I'm fascinated with your you said you
have a very big speaking fee yes but
that wasn't always the case does that
come with a self-worth thing or like no
supply and demand of of of it's a great
question
do I think people whether they're doing
standup comedy whether they're doing
anything you know cutting hair you can
cut it for 12 bucks you can cut it for
50 like sure there's that game of do you
know what you're asking for but the
market is the market like when I first
started 34 years old really speaking
well I had pretty good confidence I'm
like I really think I'm good but the
market hadn't said that I was worth what
I'm worth now okay so I think it's just
supply and demand un you know speaking
is funny and personal appearance is
funny for the human and you've been
through this and for people who go
through it or think about it it seems
crazy that you could be compensated so
well for a short period of time but in
reality there's something happening on
the back end so I could be like oh my
God I'm getting [__] flown to Madrid
and I'm going to speak for an hour and
it's I can't believe the economics I'm
making it's not like the world is Puffy
ideological yay yay the organizers of
that event in Spain are making money on
the fact that I'm there sure you know
and so it's it's very much supply and
demand sell for's a good question do I
believe a lot of people listening right
now mowing lungs cutting hair public
speaking Super Famous not known at all
doing a service business do I think most
people don't know how to ask for a
little more money the next time to keep
upping their fee yes I do and I'm glad
you asked that question um when I go do
a podcast like this I'm like okay this
is [__] an epic show with icons I'm
going to come on we're going to talk
about our subject matter but like if I
can leave in like three to seven people
here one little tidbit and all whatever
the [__] we chop up at and it becomes a
good thing for them like the thought
that somebody right now actually that
does something he's like yeah [__] and
like they charge a 100 bucks for
whatever the [__] we're talking about
right babysitting 12 bucks an hour yeah
and tomorrow the neighbor goes how much
are you and you're like $15 an hour
because you listen to this and they say
yes then we had a good [__] podcast
that's great people will say you know I
know and by the way people say no and
don't change your price back to $12 an
hour get 10 Nos and then you're like
okay I'm delusional my big thing is get
10 NOS before you go back down too many
people like are scared to go up try one
time someone says no like see [__]
Gary I was always 12 yeah you get what
you pay for yeah I'm glad that you said
that too because when I initially was
saying you know what I started to say I
was uh going to express a sensitivity
that uh speaking to my audience you know
about like like I wanted to make it
relatable to people and you just did
that for me I honestly no [__] like
I've got lots of passions but and I lots
of things I want to talk about but you
know I'm very selective of what I do and
when I do it I always think it's only
about them like I don't need people
skipping this podcast for you I don't
want to [__] you up I don't want people
to be like that suck that's not for me
if you can't make it contextual and
relatable to who's actually going to
listen then what the [__] are we doing
here right like I'm more than capable of
trying to build my own audience on my
channels I think when you go into
someone's home you take off the shoes
you know what I mean like to me the only
thing I'm thinking about right now is
how to respect y'all
and more importantly even more than you
is your audience and so like look take
me wherever you think I can bring value
but the good news is like I'm aware of
y'all and I'm a fan and like I I like
and more importantly like cool I'm a
businessman but like like I'm also a
human being like what do you think me
and my buddies did in Jersey in the 80s
and 90s dumb [__] and like you guys are
legends to us they're like oh [__] all
the dumb [__] we were doing is like real
like that so like this is fun to be with
you cool I love it thank you for that um
what's the probably a very blurry line
like uh what Viner media yes um an ad
agency and a production company yes God
so we have a production company you can
pull this one up Eva Noam Eva Noam how
do you remember all these names it's two
separate words they'll probably it's Eva
space noad Dam nosad dam Eva space here
we go there we go it's there
um so this is Madison AB spelt back WS
oh um this is our production company for
our commercials in New York in New York
at La and I own this as well this is
part of Vayner X Vayner media is the
agency even Noam is the production
company now to your point the world you
grew up in production was heavy like big
[__] it was real and so our commercials
our Super Bowl we do here our agency as
the creative Department they're also
producing actual social media ads so
that's the twist that we did to the
industry forever 70 years you had an ad
agency that came up with the ideas and
then that's what you got paid for and
then there was a production company that
would make this merch Madness by little
baty B that we did for Fanatics we still
do that as you can see here with iaos
Sadam and Vayner media but inside of
Vayner media the ad firm everybody in
Creative also makes social media
creative and that was the Twist and
that's how we changed the industry is
one of your uh contemporaries or your
Rivals at um Vayner media a company
called Sher ability are you familiar
with them yes I think that got brought
up to me the other day um um maybe um
one thing I don't do it's either my
strength or my weakness I'm almost
oblivious to competition good Blue Ocean
strategy yeah I've heard that as well
what is that it's just like there's no
competition there's no red in the
there's no blood in the Water by the way
I love competition like if you guys were
like let's THB wrestle I'd get like
super serious right now yeah yeah but
you have the mindset there's like enough
for everybody and it's abundant and by
the way if somebody's like wins
something you're absolutely I don't
think that they took it out of me I by
the way that includes like we're in a
pitch right now for we're not but I'm
going to use it because I love them if
we're in a pitch for New Balance yeah
and we're against droga 5 and
sharability and widen and Kennedy and
we're it's four of us and we lose I'm
aware that one of those three people won
M but that's the micro in the macro I'm
going to get mine for sure we're good
enough and honestly weirdly I even like
when other people first of all I kind of
weirdly like losing like I'm like you
know there's a level of like leaning
into your own humility and like you
should never always win and the Merit
and trying to figure out how to get
better at it um but yeah blue ocean def
for me it's always abundance for sure
it's like nobody stopping me but myself
if I spend a minute trying to figure out
what everybody else is doing that's a
minute I'm not figuring out the
consumers and I don't have time for that
nonsense um okay so let's uh take some
that being said in your world Vayner
watt vayer v y n r
wt.com this one I'm excited about this
is a new company for me about a year old
now and this is maybe some way we Jam
together in the future so we started a
production company good and so this is a
production company not for commercials
scripted non-scripted the guy that left
there Eric wattenberg it was at ca for
20 years then he did wheelhouse for the
last five or six years and we've teamed
up and we're just now pitching our shows
that's pretty fun I like it um for for
somebody who uh doesn't know what they
want to do who isn't even necessarily
employed yes you know H having financial
difficulty like what is your take on
that well what is your advice for like
absolutely zero to roof over your head
it's the reason I started
making garage sale videos so you can
pull up Trash Talk Gary ve I'm just you
could see I'm getting addicted with this
this pretty [__] awesome I might need
to live like this so um this this lady
was amazing anyway I this is my advice
so I started getting those emails and I
was like you know what so for the people
listening I I have good back to
different audience cross I know a good
amount may not know who I am I grew up I
was born in the Soviet Union I was born
in the USSR belus thank you my man so I
came here when I was three we lived in a
studio apartment the size of this
[__] van with like five six family
members like real humble beginning M and
so you know I didn't grow up with much
and you know in my teenage years I I
started going to garage sales and then
going to the flea market and flipping
[__] I was always into like Collectibles
that's why the vs thing is fun and all
that and then when my brother's 11 years
younger than me when my brother was like
13 I could tell my mom was trying to
make him a lawyer I'm like no no no like
AJ come with me we're going to go garage
sailing and now this new thing eBay I'm
going to we're going to sell it on this
thing MH and so how old were you I was
22 at that time time or 23 at that time
when I was teaching my brother that's
when eBay had just come out a few years
earlier and I watched my brother go from
zero to like $10,000 in cash in in a
summer because we would buy video games
for 50 cents and sell them for 20 bucks
on eBay or a shirt or anything nostalgic
pop culture things like that so my
advice is first of all I'm going to go
macro and micro in the micro right now
in America and obviously it's in some
other parts of the world but garage
sailing is bigger here in America the
quickest way to go from
$20 to your name to 10,000 which creates
some sort of breathing room of some
sorts I genuinely believe is thrift
stores and garage sales genuinely
because because it's a place where you
can buy things for a quarter 50 cents in
a dollar and get 20 you can't do that in
many other places yeah but I feel like
like the G for sure you're right okay
but if you're starting out at a thrift
store on Melrose no no [__] way
that's that's Bouie Thrift
I'm talking Goodwill like you can go to
the Goodwill it's very interesting it's
very interesting all over the country
yeah I bought some cool STS and [__] in
Oklahoma at the thrift store like and
these are like brick and mortar places
where you can go and purchase something
for like 50 cents a dollar and then but
then you take it online and you you've
got such an infinitely larger audience
yeah and it's not even your audience for
was listening say [__] I don't have an
audience no no no you just listed on
eBay you just list it on post Poshmark
you just list it on these places Mari
there's all these places now so
a00 the most logical place I see is
garage sales so so it's the Tal's oldest
time is like get a product and sell it
that's the one like I think about this a
lot because somewhere along the line I
kept telling the stories about like
early in my career after which was 10 15
years into my career after I saved some
money I made these good investments in
2006 they were called Facebook Twitter
and Tumblr and of course it changed my
life and I would talk a lot about it
talking but then I just started getting
enough emails saying like yo bro I [__]
with you Gary I love you but like I
don't have $25,000 to put in some sort
of startup so what do I do and finally
after because I read all my DMs and
email especially back in 0789 10 11 I
was really doing it because I could
manage it I was like [__] they're right
I got to talk about some other [__] and
that's how I got to this and so to
answer the question in the micro I
believe the answer genuinely is garage
sale flipping are you still doing garage
sailing to this day yeah that's me like
a couple weeks ago now at this point I'm
donating what I buy and what I sell for
to charity cuz I'm in this place in my
life but no [__] bro V like honestly
I like doing that [__] more than almost
anything I do in life here okay so so
this is great and and the problem with
most people is they're not motivated
yeah that's right and and like I I I had
a a product in 2006 that I was selling
in retail I invented this thing and I
sold it and uh go me don't do that tell
them what it is so I invented a workout
towel a workout towel the velro pocket
so you can keep all your [__] in there
while you go to the gym towel safe I
like that so so I don't it's not even
around anymore but
uh people I mean it's it's it's a
standard gy and you know like I totally
understand that was by the way that was
the easiest thing to understand of all
time that was smart yeah you fixed you
fixed the micro pain found a problem
yeah I would like that's smart but my my
theory was people were like how did you
do it it's like I think any product is a
good product it just depends on how
passionate that person is because how do
you execute and how yeah of course that
but and how much drugs you're doing and
how much drugs you're doing at the time
always a correlation but but but the
hardest part for me is like so back in
2006 I stopped listening to music when I
was driving I listen to motivational
books to keep myself that hungry and
happy now now you're now you're talking
about why Gary ve exists right like so I
was going to answer in the macro and I
love you for going to where I this is
all about people being comfortable in
their own skin not everybody to your
point let me tell you something about me
I'm motivated when we're talking about
business I'm motivated when we're
talking about kindness or like people
skills I'm not motivated when you're
talking about filling out a
form for sure like I'm in serious no no
I'm going to say this nice and slow I am
borderline incapable of administrative
duties of administrative duties yeah
yeah I'm with
you for sure we're creative yeah look
for everybody who's
listening if you do not understand
yourself and you're listening to [__]
like me or your mom or your dad or your
buddy and they're like just you can't do
that that's like telling me like just
shut the [__] up I can't I need to talk
like we have to reverse engineer truth
MH so to your point when I put out all
these videos the comments are like yeah
but the gas cost 20 bucks I'm like but I
made $800 they're like yeah but the eBay
fees I'm like yeah but I made $800 but
those are just the the weakest people
that aren't survival of the fittest like
it's not you don't have that drive to do
that then what's interesting about that
and I see where you're going is I'm
fascinated by what the internet does to
change the variable of how many don't
have to be the
weakest the option I'll give you a good
example of this in culture right now
everyone wants a [__] on jenzy entitled
lazy this that and like there's plenty
of that like look when the government
prints unlimited amounts of money during
Co and gives it to people for staying
home it [__] up people yeah like it
confuses people about Merit that being
said when I hear like some entrepreneurs
tell me like Gary this [__] gen Z I'm
like bro you're asking them to work for
$13 an hour for 10 hours a day in your
[__] store I got news for you A lot
of these kids know how to make $230 a
day in Tik Tok ads like they could sell
some T like there's these kids have
options M like like sorry they don't
want to work at Kmart for eight bucks an
hour for 53 hours a week like I don't
blame them if they know how to make it a
different way they're going too yeah and
so what what is that what was all that
about that was about there's a lot of
options and I think there's a lot of
people right now who are listening to us
with a blunt in hand and chilling and
saying like yeah I'm just not Mo I'm
just chill I'm just chill my argument is
yeah but there's some [__] you give a
[__] about something music something
yeah and by the way this is so [__]
meta you and your crew that wasn't
monetizable 20 years earlier it's true
it's very true you guys became famous
and Rich doing [__] that you couldn't
become famous and Rich for 20 years
earlier than when you did it and they
had to get somebody to say yes the
internet is like yo I'm here I'm open
for business what do you want now the
problem is the internet is also Fair
meaning when people are like Gary I'm
[__] shadowbanned on social media I'm
not doing well I'm like bro you're not
shadowbanned you just
suck like everyone's always got an
excuse like yo [__] instag do you
think Shadow band's a real thing though
sh so you you think Shadow band doesn't
not % of 1% it's not real for the guy
who's been posting the same [__] for 20
weeks and nobody gives a [__] and he's
like I'm Shadow banned I'm like you're
not Shadow banned nobody thinks you're
funny yeah and so and bro on some real
[__] I love when my content doesn't do
well when I post something and it
underperforms literally I'm like yep
[__] you Gary you thought it was good
they didn't learn next yeah so the
Internet isn't necessarily Fair it's
just highly Democratic yes and the
blockchain's even more de you know the
internet's got its variables things work
differently but here's the punchline
most things are more fair than people
want to think people want to blame a
president people want to blame their
parents people want to people want to
blame blame blame we've gotten
remarkable at pointing fingers nobody
wants to do this [__] for sure people
have like almost cut their [__]
thumbs off like people don't want to do
this [__] Steve like guys like and to me
I'm not trying to be like motivational
or rough it's just very very obvious to
me there's a direct correlation of
happiness and
accountability I love that that's that I
love I've I've Loved a lot of things
that you said that's my favorite thing
so far thank you man that's what change
my life was when I went through the step
work and you like what's my part in it
and then you start getting into the
habit of like looking at every problem
in your life and being like Oh I [__]
let me be vulnerable here a little bit I
I've done well but like you know at five
six years ago I was like hey this is me
talking to myself hey if you're such a
nice dude and like you don't care about
the money and and you really give a [__]
about your employees hey dude why then
are there people that used to work for
you that don't like you you see that
little Facebook group where they [__] on
you for employees you've seen some of
these things that they said you've
gotten emails from people that had the
courage to tell you to your face why so
I did the work you know I kept because
it bothered me I'm like man I really
want to be nice I really think I'm nice
like what am I doing wrong and finally
enough things happen both personally and
professionally where I'm like oh Gary ve
in a podcast with y'all he's canderous
cuz he's not actually talking to any
he's talking to everyone but if I cared
about you I struggled to deliver cander
believe it or not Gary vaynerchuk the
businessman my whole life I would have
very sloppy firings because I couldn't
tell because I become friends with my
employees right and then when you had to
get like if something wasn't working for
a long time it would be like all [__]
up and I didn't tell them along the way
like maybe occasionally I'd say
something but now the last five six
years there's like a real process to how
I do it like if 6 months in it's not
working I I have the strength now to sit
down in front of somebody I like and say
hey Johnny hey Susan like this not
working let me tell you what you're
doing wrong cuz there was still time to
fix it right I wasn't over the bubble of
resentment but you know and so like I
get like being accountable I sit here
and out loud say to all the people that
have ever worked for me or interacted me
where I had to fire them where they're
like what the [__] dude last week you
were saying everything was great and I'm
like you're right like I wasn't strong
enough yet oneon-one to be able to talk
about it because I thought I was scaring
you but I thought I hate fear are you a
people pleaser yes but not that bad it's
more that I hate fear and I thought if I
sat someone down and said hey shit's not
going well that they'd be scared they go
home that night and drink and cry and go
on LinkedIn and try to find a new job
and it wasn't about that yet I was
trying to find different ways to help
them but the lack of cander created a
vulnerability and then ultimately
especially if I had to let them go and I
wasn't able to figure out a different
way without ever telling them which I
did a lot but a lot I didn't it became
sloppy and I regret it and I and I own
it and it sucks but but I try to be
better now how many people you think you
fired thousands I mean I've employed you
know lots and lots of people like you
know probably 10,000 people have been
employed at Vayner through the years the
wine store probably had hundreds and
hundreds it's definitely thousand you
know and and I directly had to do
hundreds not thousands but but but at
the end of the day I always say to my
people this is just true Everything At
Vayner media my companies is my fault
and by the way at Vayner media everybody
who gets fired I have to sign off on
just to make sure my managers are not
[__] [__] up so at the end of the day
it's still my decision the the I heard a
guy say that like he was a CEO that
fired a lot of people and he said you
know the one pattern that I found out uh
that was consistent was as soon as you
get that thought of like oh this
person's got to go he's like they're
he's like and you you won't fire them
because you feel bad or whatever you
give them a chance he's like within
three months they should he's like
that's the point where they should have
been gone already yeah that there's a
lot of Truth to that I think what we've
gotten better at in our company I've
been surprised how many people have been
refurbished we call it kind cander if
you're able to with compassion take tell
not hey Johnny you suck you better get
your act together we'll you better get
your [__] together see you next week you
know like no no if you're like hey style
there's a great boxing term Styles make
fights Y what it really means for
everybody who's listening is you could
have the two best boxers in the world
fight each other but because
stylistically the way they were all of
us as fans could be bored for 12 rounds
you see in UFC as well styles Styles
make fights I use that a lot with people
I'm like hey Styles make fights just cuz
it's not working from the subjective
opinion of me and four or five of your
bosses it doesn't mean we're right
doesn't mean we're wrong it's six people
that think you're [__] up yeah but
that doesn't mean you suck like it just
means maybe you're not doing the right
thing here now what I've been surprised
about is some people are like whoa I
might get F like actually it changes
them it changes them but other people
we've changed we've changed positions
within the company other people are like
you know what I it's actually beautiful
when you can do kind cander had a dude
recently say you know what Gary I've
been wanting to write like I need to
write I need to write and like this you
know obviously I pay my bills with all
this but like this is the sign I needed
like I know I'm not showing up proper
this year because I've been distracted
because I'm writing because it's work
from home and I'm probably not working
most of the time and he was just honest
about it I was like cool bro like love
like it's not so back to Blue Ocean I
don't view my employees as my property
as my competitors like bad I view them
as family and sometimes you have [__]
[__] that's not working out and it's
okay mhm yeah what about hiring family
members I believe in it you believe you
ever had a fire family
member um not really but I've had to
have like conversation like to me the
reason I like hiring family members is
first of all my dad has fired both me
and my sister so big shout out to Sasha
vaynerchuk who has no problem firing
family members
um uh I got fired for one day my sister
permanently sorry Liz um I think that uh
to me I like I think people tell you
know that old saying right don't hire
family or friends yeah I think it's a
mistake I think it works a lot I think
if now I would say 48-year-old Gary is
far more should hire family and friends
now than 25-year-old Gary because the
lack of cander led to resentment and
awkwardness so I think it comes down to
do you believe you and the person you're
hiring has a communication structure and
what I've always done with family is I'm
like listen to me I and running this
business for everyone and I can't create
an
eptisa effort into finding a spot for
them I do that for anyone you came in as
an account manager maybe you should be a
creative you came in as a creative maybe
you should be a back office per like I
think companies give up on people too
fast um would you be a 50-50 partner
with a family member I have been did it
work out it worked out because me and my
brother are pretty remarkable at this
and I'm going to tell this story because
I hope this helps someone my brother and
I my brother comes out of school he's 22
I'm 33 we start this company bayner
media we start off 50-50 I had all the
cred I had all the credibility in the
market I had the money like I was the
guy but I still went 50/50 because
because I had just come out of forming
not resentment but I just went through
building a big company for my dad and
owning nothing so I was overly
empathetic for my brother plus my
brother I already knew was t did and I
had no clue how it was going to play out
but we did something smart and I hope
this helped someone we said to ourselves
day one we're going to go 50/50 and we
have no idea what's going to happen but
whatever happens we trust each other
enough that we'll adjust in the future
to try to make it as good as we can as
good as we can or as Fair as we can you
know I would use both of those words
similar to the best of our ability
loving each other and trying to
communicate let me tell you what
happened correctly you're saying well
we'll start 5050 and as we go we'll
adjust it to what's appropriate but you
can't adjust it so easily because
there's tax implication there's a lot
that comes along with that right it
couldn't be like my dad my if let's say
I wasn't doing anything like here you go
AJ here's 30% of the company he has to
pay taxes on it like it it it would
become so challenging so yes and you can
do that but for everyone listening do
your homework on how tax law works and
all this it's not so easy let me tell
you how it played out I thought cuz I
was the older brother and I had other
aspirations as well that I would work
with him for a while and eventually he'd
become the CEO and I'd go do the next
thing and he would run it my brother has
Crohn's disease at about 25 about 3 26
about three four years in maybe a little
bit further five six seven years in he
has a tough uh spell and he has to take
like I think 12 inches out of his
intestines has surgery I come in and
he's like yo like he's in the hospital
comes I could see who was shook about I
I don't remember perfectly but a couple
months later maybe within the year he
comes in and he says I want out and I
was like [__] okay like first of all my
my I'm 11 years older than him so first
my older brother slfa intins come in I'm
like I got you then I'm like then I
settled down from that I was like yo we
need to talk about this yeah at this
point he says he wants out how big is
the company pretty big I mean it's
bottom line is I had to buy my brother
out for real
money then we started a company called
Vayner Sports this is but you have to
hear the most important part of uh of
this story yes I have to buy him out and
yes I was a big impact on how much we
were doing overall and were we 5050 we
were not and I feel comfortable if AJ
sat here he would say Gary did more and
was a bigger impact but then we started
vayer Sports and to my brother's credit
Jee he's working 100% on this I'm
impacting it and recruiting and
different things like this but this is
what we're doing and look at our guys
this by the way weird moment Sidetrack
in the time of this filming the Jets
which are my entire life I love the New
York Jets more than anything are playing
the Falcons this weekend and it's the
first time my team is playing one of my
quarterbacks and I'm very weirded is it
still a huge goal of yours to own the
Jets yes sir yeah anyway I'll finish
this to move on to next part we start
this company my brother's GNA be on
fulltime and I think if I remember at
the beginning I got 85% of company he
got 15 because we were going to work on
trying to make it
fair and but he's putting in more Sweat
Equity yeah and what so how what are you
bringing to the table at 85 and he's at
15 making up for what happened on Vayner
media oh now I'm also me I [__]
recruited most of the like I'm a beast
and I'm right that's what you're
bringing to the table but but even but
to my brother's credit I want to give
him his flowers even if I never spent a
minute on this company I would own 85%
of it because that was him holding his
bargain of his word at 22 that we would
see what would happen at Vayner media
and we would always adjust and we're but
how was that conversation talking about
splitting shares at the time for this
one yeah easy because me and my brother
got lucky and I want everybody hear it
again if you feel like you have a family
member who if you set out to like will
always try for each other that leaves a
lot of room for you never talking to
that person again well my my people
always ask me like uh you know I have a
thing with a business partner and uh
what I say is like if if somebody asked
me if they want to go in the business
with a friend or whatever I say if
you're going to do that because you have
to make sure your operating agreement is
so explicit that it everything there's a
step for anything that can [__] up cuz
like what do you do if you know he goes
on drugs yeah you got to assume the
absolute worst and address by the way
you two just crushed the [__] out of
that last you're not the bad guy both
are unbelievably right and comma so we
don't live in fantasy land and it's
still going to be gnarly no matter what
you could have the perfect plan in place
with everything covered you could assume
the worst and I promise you N9 years
later when there's real money involved
and it's not even the money it's the
feelings I [__] worked every Friday
night like like I'm even getting the
Goosebumps I always get these when I
know we talking about something
important like just
assume and then you and then to your
point here we go we spied it out for the
last s minutes you decide it's on you
has it worked for some yes does it not
work out for most yes and you're not the
bad guy the piece of paper is the bad
guy but you know this even with that
[__] changes a decade later like please
dude you don't understand I just had a
bad couple I went to rehab dude I'll
I'll make up for it it's like dude
[__] and there's [__] you don't think
about when you both started out as
Brothers cousins whatever you wen't in
relationships now you get married one of
the wives has a point of view on some
[__] and and by the way even if it's not
that gnarly what if it's not even weird
like the wife has a point of view two
sisters start a company the husbands get
involved and they're both beautiful
perfect marriages and and it's all good
feelings but one of the sides of the
marriages just want a different level of
work life balance with their two kids
than the other side and have different
goals and Ambitions it's all good but
what do you do now you're 50/50 and one
person's saying I want to work 9 to 5 4
days a week so cuz I want to with my
kids and the other side's like whoa
we're about to explode I want to double
down now it's now what now are do you
have the you have a shotgun clause and
you can buy out the original like
there's this is [__] it's complicated
but let me say this to someone who's
spent his whole life working with his
father and his brother it's the [__]
best when it's right yeah but okay so
here's the question no no go ahead well
I want to say Can can you be clear to
the to the audience members or whoever
you're speaking to like don't do a
handshake deal always put it in writing
right if you do a handshake deal which
I've done those things too it will
almost always end up with anxiety at the
end almost always yeah so yes I think
you're giving people very good advice if
you make a very detailed contract you
always have something protecting the
relationship the paper the contract can
be can take some of the energy what's
interesting I'm saying this mean Steve
have handshake deals but I'm just saying
like if you're going you guys have
confidence each it's this is a different
like like we understand each other very
well no but I'm going to say it again
you just sat here and said you
understand each other differently I just
sat here and said me and my brother and
this is what I'm saying there's no one
siiz fits-all are there a billion
relationships that got totally [__]
because of business yes are there tens
of thousands that work beautifully
because they understand each other yes
you just have to be accountable what you
are walking into and have your eyes wide
open yeah fair enough yeah okay the the
question that that's burning on the tip
of my tongue is uh who surfaced the
number 85 and 15 so on the record it's
it's good news it's somewhere in that
range by the way it might have been 8020
I don't recall this is 78 years old who
surfaced it I believe it went down I'm
not remembering because obviously it
went so well and easy it's not something
I remember so vividly I believe my
brother said hey of course we're going
to whack this up up in a different way
based on what's been going on with
Vayner media because that's what we
talked about and I think if it happened
right this second here's what would have
happened and I think this is how it went
down and I would have said cool why
don't you come to me with what works for
you and then and then that's what I
remember happening here here's here's my
uh what my gut tells me please when
you're negotiating with somebody and and
you need to to arrive at a a split um
it's always going to be better for you
to to tell the person to suggest what
they're thinking and less about the
number Landing for me I've learned even
when we did Vayner Sports which was
seven or eight years ago I've learned
that money isn't my driver because I'm
capable of making it and because I like
the game more than the trophies so it's
always works for me that way because I'm
less likely to be upset about five or
10% less than I think I was worth but I
don't want the other person that feel
that way because they may get [__] up
because for a lot of people they don't
have the same mindset as I do H and
again here's me giving advice that I
don't take myself because I'm always
like I'll give you this yeah he likes to
give out percentages before he sees p&l
statements because I get it bro it's I
honestly bro I'm not a great negotiator
by any stretch I'm about Vibes and
people and stuff like that I'm a good
businessman I'm not like whatever but I
get it I get but do you have a shark on
your team that does that for you no but
I have Mark yudkin who's my guy he's my
lawyer he's my CEO he's like my
consilier he definitely like provides a
even my brother represents that for me a
lot they're definitely more straight and
like try to keep it in Pocket the
problem is everybody knows like push
comes to shove I won't listen to anybody
meaning like they TR there's been plenty
of times where I'm like and they're like
dude and I'm like and I'm like and
they're like dude I'm like d and they're
like dude and I'm
like like you know like now there's also
plenty of times where I'm like and
they're like dude I'm like yeah you're
right [__] I got to you know like so
that's how it works yeah I like well we
do that with Steve a lot but when he's
so dead set on that I honestly just like
dude well you have the vision [__] we
got you that's it and that's it and
that's it and and like this is great I'm
so pumped that a lot of people are
listening to this right now because this
is going on a lot right now with a lot
of people are listening they've got
their crew they're trying to figure out
these Dynamics and look I'm sure you
guys will say this and I'll say it
there's no right way there's some great
principles we've talked a lot about them
for the last 10 minutes but like
honestly let me give you the last point
on this unless you guys keep talking
about it just try like [__] hell to
remember you love the other person like
your boy your like if somebody if my dad
was here and you asked him why did you
and Gary work out even though there was
potential for it not to work out family
business are hard and he would say cuz
we just loved each other just a little
bit more than our feelings towards every
issue and that was right we loved each
other just a couple percentage points
more than what was pissing us the [__]
off first one the love wins 100% love
you for that that's absolutely right
yeah and when you're 90 none of this
shit's going to [__] matter when the
person that you're mad at right now is
on their death bed right it's real man
like could you imagine if somebody calls
somebody right now that they've haven't
talked to for seven years because of a
bad business breakup like a brother or
sister-in-law or Mom and reconcile the
relationship how cool is that that we
did that sure yeah um Ste was like I
don't give a
[__] I think that's great but but I'm
just I'm just very very fixated on
something that you just said um that
nobody's going to none of this is going
to matter when you're 90 years old and
then for me and I know this is important
to Scott as well that come when you're
90 and and it doesn't matter but then
you die in your life review you
experience all of the uh feelings that
you cause other people in every
circumstance have you ever heard of that
like we're big into these YouTube videos
that um near experien people people
recount their experiences having died
and come back to life and
they what do they say they uh so they
they go through when they you know when
they die they go through the tunnel they
meet their guide or whatever and uh this
right here that uh near-death
experiencers undergo a Life review in
which the meaning of their life is
presented to them but also how their
life affected other people as well as an
awareness of the thoughts and feelings
of those people you experience whole
life as honestly I have literally my
whole life up into this nanc wanted to
live forever I'm so looking forward
going through that it'd be interesting
when I tell you when I die and go
through it and they review all the [__]
that you just showed me I'm going to be
smiling like a [__] I have so
much more Goodwill towards random human
beings human beings in general than
anybody I've ever met and I say this
because it's an outlandish statement as
a compliment to my parents predominantly
my mother what did I do they made me I
am stunned on a daily basis How Lucky I
Am of how nice I feel towards every
human of all shape sizes and angles
especially in the world we live in now
where everyone's just trying to at all
cost around anything it we ran out of
[__] to be mad at each other for
religion race gener now we're on
Generations now we're teaching humans
okay hey everyone if you're in gen Z you
have to hate Boomers and hey Millennials
you have to hate like I'm like watching
all this [__] and I'm like [__]
so anyway seeing this for the first time
I'm pretty fired up I'm looking forward
to it I'm gonna grab some popcorn have
God show me my [__] and I think I'm
going to crush it you said you once said
something that really uh struck a chord
with me was uh I want to be remembered
for giving more than what I took when I
tell you I it similar to what we're
saying here and maybe you've heard this
as well I'm not sure I haven't said I
used to say it all the time I haven't
said it recently I literally literally
live my life based on how many people
are going to show up to my fun funeral I
believe most people do not show up to
funerals unless it's really really
really that person like I think back to
my life and watching like funerals and
being like I cannot believe X wasn't
like you know like obviously like to
compel someone to go to your their
funeral you had to have a real impact
yeah like actually and like look I've
I'm very fortunate 48 I've been to I've
been unfortunately I've been to a lot of
funerals in the business world and boy
I've I remember when I was 19 I went to
this one funeral and there was like nine
people there and I was like makes sense
he just was not
nice you he laughing it was like
Honestly though it was very real to me I
was like this guy was profoundly
successful in the business the liquor
business that I was a part of but he was
just genuinely not kind and like and I
saw it all manifested right there and
I'm like mm I'm going to do the reverse
of this [__] yeah and I'm and I was such
a [__] I'm like and I'm going to
build a much bigger
business with with the the This Life
review thing it's the saying is you see
your life flash before your eyes I know
everybody's heard that and it's like
like like all of these people who have
had near-death experiences are are are
describing the same thing and what's
crazy about it like to make you even
more excited and maybe the rest of us
less excited is that is that the the the
construct of time is something that like
only really applies in this physical
realm but like on the other side the way
they describe it it's just like there's
just there's not uh uh it's not in the
confin of so the detail like you can
feel like like from like the perspective
of a misquito that's off like 300 yards
over there like the the detail like the
the the detail of the experience and
without any uh constraint of time is
like so like beyond our compreh can you
please stop talking because I literally
like am getting too excited and I still
got a ton of [__] do
die right and and I I I feel very
strongly that I've done more good than
bad but man do I have a something I
think you'll enjoy I think you're going
to enjoy this because I think about this
as well and now you just said it and
Trigger something I am so excited to
give you this these flowers that I'm
about to give
you we're all living life you're a
public figure um in the business World
moving and shaking
20 times in the last 20 years I am so
excited to tell you I love the way
people talk about you that actually know
you w cool man thank
you yeah you do good business for the
most part and like and it's funny it's
sometimes not even like I'm very
talkative and extroverted and talk to a
lot of people even one I remember is
like how you treated someone at a
restaurant okay they told me they they
were actually paying me a compliment
comparing me to you the way you also
treated them nice oh that's cool yeah so
definitely business like he was great on
the Sho or this and that but like people
are watching we're affecting people and
not just people that are known all of us
every human like if you're a human
walking by and another human that
doesn't have any followers or one
they're not nice you feel that it's
really funny I'm like I do this a lot
it's my natural state I've been doing it
since I was eight I really enjoy smiling
at people like it's really interesting
man like no [__] no like hahaa or
whatever just like real talk like just
like seeing somebody at Dunkin Donuts
getting coffee and they're in front of
you line you just look at them you're
like like a little I like to do a little
hand and like people really like it well
there's some funny Reactions where if
you smile at somebody then they look
away and they they smile you notice that
they like weird out but they look away
and they realize and then they smile as
they're looking away it's just it's
really sad like I feel like Civility and
loving your neighbor like some of the
[__] that was actually really I've been
thinking about this a lot the last month
oh [__] this the this how I think about
stuff oh [__] we've put youth on a
pedestal youth yeah these kids know
technology jenz has a say they're going
to be better than us and we've really
started to disrespect our elders they
don't get it they [__] up the world
for us they don't know how to use
technology and for all these years it
was the reverse right right respect your
elders I saw something that [__] me up
the other day these three kids good
dudes they weren't trying to do they
weren't like Hans but they were just
sitting on the F at the airport on these
three chairs and this 80-year-old lady
like clearly was looking for a I was on
the phone having a business call but I
was watching it and I was like dude how
the [__] is nobody getting up for this
lady and like that would have never
happened in 1954 every [__] person
would got up yeah I've done that the
other thing too is that old people serve
as a reminder of our mortality and if we
don't want to think about our mortality
I think there's some validity to that I
just think we underestimate wisdom sure
I just think we do okay how about this
um the uh the the idea of having
children yes you know back in the in the
beginning of the country and and and in
and work on the farm times yeah we
needed them workers yeah you needed
workers and you wanted to have more
children so that when you in your like
end of your life you would have these
children to care for you it was the you
were setting yourself up with caregivers
that's right and somewhere along the
line I'm going to guess it was somewhere
between the Boomers and the Gen xers Y
that uh that that that that shifted to
where children uh were no longer uh
future caregivers they the children
became really expensive
pets and and that's all it is as a kid
is like you have have children now
you've got really expensive pets yes
that you have to take care of at fully
into their adulthood like I saw I saw a
statistic um in
1940 um like over uh over 90% of every
kid
um would uh be more successful than
their than their parents then in 1980
that became a 50-50 coin flip 1980 it
became a 5050 coin flip so what is it
now what percentage do you think of
Jen's ears have
15 that's the general area we're going
to find out we more success do better
than their parents you know um oh wa
jenzy most likely to say they're doing
better than their parents okay that
doesn't tell us anything well yeah what
were um did you have a stat in mind that
you're going to say I I don't know I
only know I only all I saw was 1940 I
think what you're saying is like cuz
most geners are like dude I can't even
afford a [__] house now well right I
mean and that's the thing like I got out
of ectomy because uh you know multiple
reasons but very major uh influence on
me getting the sectomy was what I
considered to be just dwindling
opportunity like they you hear people
say the American dream uh you know isn't
what it would used to be yeah you know
I'm a I'm more optimistic than that I by
the way I understand all of that and
there's plenty of validity to have that
conversation I think there's a couple
problems first I think it's hypocrisy
let me explain you have all these gen Z
kids saying like [__] my parents they
[__] up [__] and they're 24 and
they're on the
payroll right like like so first it's
really s hard to say well I can't do it
or this sucks and you're not changing
the narrative for yourself meaning our
lack of patience of eating [__] for a
period of time to get to where we want
to get to is Gone Gone Gone the reason
so many people were able to make it was
you thought that it would take 15 years
for you to make it MH now you tell
someone who's 21 it's going to take 15
days to make it way and they're like nah
man I ain't got that time I'm like bro
all you got is time now a couple things
one I'm generalizing I've met an ungodly
amount of 18 to 22 year olds who are on
fire who want to [__] do it plenty of
that but it has become because some
people popular culture is [__] up
people because Mark Zuckerberg could in
seven years because of the internet get
to a tril everyone's like yo you know
the top 1% in America the richest
country in the world the top 1% Mak
650,000 a year lot of money but every
kid that's 19's like if if you tell them
well you're only going to make a million
year they like damn I suck they think
it's like so easy it's impossible
YouTube influencer money that's right
and so every everyone's confused so
couple things I get that I understand
why that's happening separation of
wealth is an issue it's all Roman Empire
[__] but here's my thing as a human
don't be discouraged meaning okay the
American dream listen I love America I
immigrated here from the Soviet Union I
[__] love this place but really as a
human it's all about accountability if
someone if I was 19 and somebody told me
bro 10 years from now it's a wrap
nothing can happen here my next question
would be like where does it happen and
if they were like Australia I'd be like
let's [__] go like like to me it's
like okay like honestly you know it's
like I there's always an option like I'm
so pumped next year's an election year
mainly because all my buddies and
friends and acquaintances and business
associates are all going to say the same
dumb [__] if x or y whichever one of the
two wins I'm leaving I've been doing
this for 20 years there's not a
[__] that moved to Canada yeah
do you want to be in the frying pan or
the fire this time
around neither neither neither the the
ice box eating some I think 2024 is
going to be a good year because I think
the fed's going to start dropping the
rate because it's an election year
Bitcoin having I think the crypto
markets are going to start popping off
so then the real estate where you at
with the real estate market if they're
going to be dropping the rates do you
think though that there's going to be
more inventory I don't one thing I like
is I speak with a ton of conviction of
what I know and I tread lightly where I
don't know don't know real estate I
watch it I'm a human being I like
business I like pop culture it's all
part of it but no I don't have the
expertise I think what I do have is I'm
good at history and of course to your
point if interest rates start coming
down [__] starts to happen of course
people aren't going to buy [__] when
money's got an 8% big on it and it did
like like this is very historical um
there's also Trend changing meaning
shit's changing like where people want
to live how people want to live now it's
Zoom life like it's like when some kid
the other day said Gar I'm just going to
live around the world and do all my
meetings and I'm like I get it and they
can and they can I'm like get it I'm
like yeah you like van life yeah bro
like I'm like I get it like like like to
me everything's like why not like
everyone wants to look at yesterday
without understanding where tomorrow's
going like why can't you be a kid and by
the way once you make that shift the
places you can live if you love the
outdoors and you're a little bit more
Rural and stuff like that like some of
the [__] like sometimes I get weird and
just Google [__] I'm like 900 acres and
weird in like weird do it right now 900
acres in Pennsylvania like watch this
right you ever do this Zillow porn yeah
it's like it's like just click anything
like I don't know there you go the first
one I don't give a [__] pay the [__]
ad fee
l.com um like some of this [__] play
figure it out I believe you you've been
very good at navigating this he's a he's
a genzer look at this this shit's crazy
to me here we go 845 Acres look at
this 88 now that's 11 do do me what I'm
looking find me like three acres for
like $4 go like least
price 800 acres for a million two that's
like 800 soccer
fields that's crazy isn't this like I
look at this stuff so I think about
somebody who loves the woods actually
let's just use this 878 acres in Alabama
you got it right there bottom left third
fourth one down if you don't mind with
the river not that one go down left down
down that right there that's pretty the
creek let's just look at this for a
second look $3.5 million is a ton of
money let's put things into perspective
comma 800 78 Acres so if you're someone
who genuinely loves that
life and you needed and you wanted to
live in New York City and work in New
York City and to get this kind of thing
you had to go to the Hamptons where it
cost $8 million for a half a acre or you
could just chill in [__] odil Alabama
what the [__] this is and have 878 hunt
every day work live off the [__] food
in the land and the whole that [__] and
like but you could go on Zoom all day
from your [__] and that goes for San
Diego and that goes for some tropical
place that we can probably Google Now
like the world's changing and I love
that and so I'm not like honestly I'm
not worried about my mom made more money
than me or the American Dreams done
here's the punchline the American dream
has been going on for a 100 years and
there's been unlimited [__] who've
been
losing more than 100 years that's
250 but branded branded is the American
dream branded all right and during that
time steo unlimited dudes and gals were
losing mhm the American dream was
opportunity now it's going away there
will be unlimited opportunity for people
in America and everywhere else the
question becomes what are you going to
do about it because I promise you if you
stand all day and Google and go through
your feed and completely believe that
your generation can't have it as good as
your parent generation well then it's a
wrap and it's already over yeah I like
that I I I like that a lot man let me uh
let me ask you this you find what you're
looking for you want to say the world's
all [__] up I can show you 900 things
right now on the internet and you're
right you want to say the world's
awesome I can show you 900 things and
tell you the problem is 95% are in that
first part right now is that victim
mentality 100% it's all perception it's
easier it's easier to be a victim then
you have to do [__] about it well feels
good to point people love a good [__]
point yeah um he's getting too super
into it yeah look at him he just forgot
he was on the
van yeah let me let me ask you this cuz
I know
I think a lot of people are always
learning you know H how did you how did
you know this my my biggest question in
my 20s were like dude these [__]
millionaire like how did they how do
they know this and and I started you
know reading Tony Robbins books or or
Rich Dad Poor Dad and then I started say
well how did they know that and then I
kept tracing it back to well they all
got their information from Napoleon
Hills think can grow rich and that's my
favorite book and it's it's the
bestselling self-help book of all time
love it do you have a a book no that's
not how I I don't I've learned that I
don't have I have real uh reading
comprehension issues I was an ' 80s kid
so I didn't get diagnosed but I don't
read books what what I've learned from
is the market but H but I'll explain
yeah it
it so where you were going yeah I can't
explain to you why at 600 or 7 when it
snowed in Jersey and everybody started
building a snow and sledding that I
wanted to get a shovel and ring
doorbells and be like can I shovel your
driveway for five bucks nobody taugh you
that nobody taught me that my dad my mom
was an 80s mom just go outside and play
it was very cool it was awesome and my
dad was never around worked which I
respect the [__] I'm saying that in a
good way like he was building our
family's life it was just naturally in
My DNA I was like I was actually
genuinely I think truly entrepreneurial
it was just my makeup but what taught me
all what I learned was the doorbell
ringing was the baseball card shows was
stocking the shelves at my dad's store
I'm inherently curious and I pay
attention so even as young as like 12
doing baseball card shows when when
someone's like how much is that and I
was like oh this Cal Ripkin Jr is 20
bucks and they'd be like oh no I would
always analyze what went down when I
would ring doorbells as a kid no I
remember not just being like scared most
people are scared to get the know which
is why I don't do it I wasn't even not
only not scared I was always like
fascinated by like what did I say how
did I say I was very introspective so I
think a lot of mine was natural and then
what I was learning was learning on the
job as you hear people talk about
anything in life so I'm a better learner
living it than I am reading it and I
think a lot of things came natural which
is why I actually think my platform has
played out the way it is I think when I
hit the scene a decade ago and I was
like okay now let me give the game to
the kids I was saying it's so different
and saying different [__] because I
think I did it a different way and so
like I'm very grateful for being like I
feel like I feel I can I can step out of
my own self and be like oh okay Gary you
you were pretty you were original enough
that that it brought but it was based on
I'm sure if I read those books I'd like
oh [__] yeah they knew like I never
think I I don't think anything I do is
new I'm sure it's you and I promise you
long before Napoleon Hill like somebody
like well yeah cuz his whole thing was
he he hung around with like the
billionaires of like the 1900s and he
studied their thing and he wrote into a
principle but the like the billionaires
knew and he and they exactly but I think
there's Universal truths to like I
hustle hustle muscle and and hustle
muscle is you know and now we've like
made cancelled I mean that was such a
pain in the ass that's canceled yeah
like can hustle muscle hustle it's like
a bad like that because people turned it
into
burnout
and like and honestly and I get it by
the way nobody wants I like how trains
popped up for hustle muscle um uh yeah
well D look at this kid that the
universal truths of work ethic are real
it well they're they come from somewhere
Network networking is real like people
[__] make [__] happen yeah like you
know like uh I I think a big one that is
not tell me if I'm wrong you I I like
that you know some of this stuff well I
think humility is a big one of course I
think humility is like it's not like
what dudes want to talk about enough I
think humility is a [__] superpower
like if you don't get high on your own
Supply it's just enjoyable people will
could because you reach a certain level
and so many people are insecure they
start talking [__] about people because
they got somewhere and it [__] you up
like I think genuine humility is a beast
of a builder like I think uh of 100%
yeah I mean I'm I never want to bus
tables again I I love that and I love um
I think being scared of going there it's
more of like no look we've been
fortunate the three of us right we
worked for that I don't think like I got
lucky like of course you get lucky that
you didn't die or you were born at all
like you could I don't like when people
weaponize luck so that they don't have
to do [__] no but of course we're
fortunate but we've worked hard and
we're here right but the reality is is
that once you get there how you act is
like incredibly fascinating to me I mean
look you guys know you guys have been
around like watching I I hate that
people don't understand that money and
fame they don't change you they expose
you they uh yeah yeah I I I couldn't
agree more it uh it it um emphasizes it
uh exaggerates it uh magnif magnifies
your TR it exposes you 100% I'm telling
you it just does I've just met too many
people I've been around too long now
it's too obvious if you were a great
dude before it happened and you get
money you become a really great dude if
you were miserably hurting inside and
the way you got successful there's only
two ways to get successful deep deep
conviction gratitude like happiness or
the reverse deep anxiety and neg like
I'm going to show you [__] everyone like
they are
superpowers oo I definitely it's Star
Wars it's like the dark side and the
Jedi are super close and the Jedi are
just going to win by just a little bit
like plenty people make money because of
Darkness it's just hard to sustain it
once you're there yeah I remember in my
20s I would go to I would go to bed
every night see you like that well I I
do because um when uh when I was
dropping out of the University of Miami
in
1993 I had been dumped by this girl she
said she was looking into her future she
couldn't see me in it she wanted to be
successful in life she wanted to have
stuff she thought I was going to be a
loser like it it it really really I
really understand where she was coming
from well there was no president for
what I was trying to do she like she
like talking you're talking about you're
going to become a crazy famous stunt man
with a video camera like I don't get it
I really do like I mean it this goes
back to how the world works but go ahead
I I don't this I I don't get it like I
just I can't you know like and were you
in love and I mean you had a big crush
on her she had been my girlfriend and I
mean I don't know like
a year and that's a long time oh a year
w that in that time of your life the
year is like everything yeah yeah I mean
a whole semester and then we were aart
for the summer like uh don't downplay it
fans he was super in love you could
see it was his first love Yeah was it
your first was in yeah right and and so
and and nothing what's her name her name
was Tracy and there's nothing wrong last
name I'm kidding there's nothing wrong
I'm not disar was right Tracy was right
she wanted better for herself and and
she had to have boundary and and and me
I was blowing it I was blowing it I I
wasn't going to class I was drunk all
the time I failed out I got kicked out
she couldn't have been more right but it
hurts so much to be told that she
thought I was just going to be a loser
in life that like when that when I when
I proceeded on with the video camera and
trying to do the
stunts every year Tracy received a VHS
tape of how badass like my my the the
the filming that I did like each year
the the tape that I mailed to Tracy got
more and more bad how long were you
doing that for I what started in last
week yeah it
started she just got the Buckle
theil it it started like when uh I mean
she she dumped me in
1993 I certainly uh was presenting
footage to her like whenever I had the
chance in person
like uh mailed a tape in 1996 1997 19
like uh by by 1998 like uh there were
actual like professional Graphics bed in
because I was showing up in like and and
so like I I I just so genuinely it
resonated with you when you're like [__]
you know and I'll show you f it's funny
wow when you told that story like the
way I would think about I don't have
that same gear but when I do think about
trying to have that gear or like what
would do in that gear I wouldn't have
gone I would have gone the other way I
think the more gangster version is
nothing and just know you're going to
get that Outreach in 10 years that
Outreach that long game like I've gotten
some fun outreaches when I was started
to pop 10 15 years ago and it was
deliciously satisfying yeah yeah but
it's okay to get like motivation out of
SP out of spite and like look but I do
think I will say this brother and I
think it's fair but I will say this
because I really am fascinated by this
subject matter I tell everybody who's
motivated by Spite try to tweak it
because when it is your driver when you
get there it's not like like like when I
hear that he's also a humorous dude like
for sure like to your point I think the
way you're saying just make sure it's
not 100% spite cuz when it's 100% spite
when it's that pure Darkness it gets
dark when you get there totally yeah I I
just mean by like like this one chick
broke up with me and I was like oh I
just want to get better looking and just
like also for my health and like to look
better on camera and all that stuff but
it was like just like no I want to show
her that like what she's
am I seeing your eyes right are your
eyes that pretty yeah they're pretty
pretty my
God I was like listening I was like
listening to him talk and I was like man
he's got some pretty [__] up chicks
fall over head over heels dude and he's
like it's the eyes dude I'm tell guys
I'm telling you it's eyes I'm so blown
away that people have not figured this
out we need to do a lot like all these
people are trying to look good I'm like
man if they just realized it's that you
should do a little contact lenses like
the eyes are the eyes are the game to
the soul dude I'm tell thank you close
I'm pretty far away right now and just
like they were glowing from here I was
like no I think they're pretty thank you
that light eyye dark hair thing is real
yeah very Eastern European if you Vinnie
yeah thanks Scott I think that I think
that there's so much Merit so much value
in that and and if I'm honest I
absolutely was like I wanted to show
show her I wanted to show everybody I
wanted to show everybody and it's been a
huge help for me like in stand up like
oh people don't I'm going to show them
I'm that's a healthy SP and for me what
was interesting was back to some of the
stuff we just talked on brother I've
been curious the whole time to me it's
like how big can I make this it's been a
very like almost like an curious
engineer I say in my head sometimes I'm
like I like it because I'm I really want
to make my parents proud that that I've
realized is a big one that's a big
driver for for me making them proud like
real like even now like I can already
start to like feel getting a little you
know like I I love it I I'm so grateful
thank God they got me I was born
literally in the least entrepreneurial
place on Earth for all the kids that are
listening the USSR was like North Korea
you weren't allowed to leave I was
literally born in a
country a communist country that you
weren't allowed to leave like America
passes some like weird like like
California New York passed like some
subtle law and they're like social no no
I in real socialism like and so like I'm
so grateful so hey I know I'm driven
that I want to make them proud which is
awesome but I am I've become very
curious on the Merit on the blue ocean
thing I'm a big thinker of like a big
believer not thinker big believer of
like to build the biggest building in
town there's two ways to do it either
you just are capable of building it or
you spend your time tearing it down
everybody else's buildings and I watch
people and they really like number two
they build a decent sized building and
then they spend all their energy [__]
tearing everybody else's down mhm and
I'm just kind of on like how Okay 40
stories 50 stories 70 you know like I
sit here just turned 48 Real Talk guys
real talk I know we're just getting to
know each other I'm like I'm just
starting yeah sure like of course I know
I've done [__] but like I've got juice
for these next 30 40 MH like and and not
like because I want like just cuz why
wouldn't I want to
play you can't see yourself retiring no
I really can't ever no and and only
because whatever I would do instead of
building companies is not as fun the way
someone loves golf or sailing or cooking
like I like I like what I'm doing right
now more than those things I don't want
to go water skiing like [__] your golf
clubs like like this is more fun I'll go
garage sailing yeah but yeah no I I
don't want to not retire because I want
to make more or like whatever like it's
just fun pure bread anything pure bread
comic purebred mother purebred teacher
guidance counselor sailor Plum like pure
bread is pure bread I am a pure bread
entrepreneur there's nothing more fun to
me than doing stuff in business it's
super fun and it's not about the money
like it's just not yeah I'm a pure bread
attention [__] I get it yeah we're
getting Steve into the affiliate
marketing game so I've been researching
all that kind of [__] that's going to be
exciting next chapter sure that the only
thing in that game is make sure you
believe in what you're selling sure yeah
that's the big one that's where that
gets [__] up you got there's like you
got to really find it yeah no we we made
a cool list of like things that he
actually uses and stuff so that that and
they by the way you know what's going to
be huge is finally it looks like I've
been waiting for this it finally looks
we're in a prus in America of of live
shopping so in China for the last decade
all all the social networks live
shopping is a monster like you're going
through and you're picking out actually
virtually no nope Q
QVC like video on I mean um on the man
put uh live shopping China uh lady with
handbags there's something that went
pretty viral recently this is the most
insane video like QVC but on your phone
I'm saying Tik Tok live I I'm saying my
man right here oh like social media yeah
and Tik tok's already doing that didn't
Tik Tok just start that um yep Amazon's
doing it everyone's gonna do it I
believe that St as you go through your
experimenting of affiliate because I'm
getting a sense of you got some chops
you're going to be like wait a minute
[__] affiliate links let's go live on
Tik Tok for two hours a day and sell
[__] all right that'd be interesting
hell yeah dude well dude this is this is
epic and and here we're like it's live
put live shopping it's less selling it's
live
shopping on
social
China China
China in China the future of shopping is
already happening that's right this
whole phenomenon this I think you would
crush cuz you're actually entertaining
and you're actually talented and and and
like by the way I'll just do it right
now one of the ways I was going to tell
you to explode the living [__] out of
this is to set up a Tik Tok shop and go
on Tik Tok for an hour a day and just
[__] doing what you guys do best you
will be flabbergasted of what's going to
happen and flabbergasted I have no idea
what I just said flabber guested uh yeah
this this this phenomenon is coming and
it's coming fast but do you think but do
you think like with Tik Tok yes it
becoming this live shopping thing it's
going to kill the whole creative nope
like posting I believe in the world of
and there's enough for everybody Vinnie
you know what I mean Vinnie like do I
believe that the hour spent on so do I
believe the hour someone's gonna watch
steo and and you three selling this
joking around trying different dishes
bringing on people with their products
to like put it on does that hour come
away from somebody scrolling in feed and
maybe watching a 30-minute video of me
or something else sure but that's going
on every day every hour right I mean
it's it's either that or they're going
to watch someone play a video
game look what's happening there where
it's kind of been happening this is
coming to America and it's going to be
[__] bananas and you guys I'm kind of
pumped right now that we stumbled into
this combo cuz I'm convinced in a year
one of you is going to DM me or text me
it'll chop it up and you'll be like holy
[__] dude that's how big this is going
to be now how do you especially for
someone like you who can actually do
[__] some people suck dick on camera
yeah yeah yeah yeah but okay how do you
they're not going to sell [__] Vinnie
how are you so you will CU they're just
going to zoom in on your eyes and people
are going be like I'll take five because
he recognizes patterns that's what I was
going to ask because like you you
predicted like Facebook buying Instagram
you predicted uh WhatsApp thing and then
Jo it's just all at this because I put
in the work I pay attention I've been
watching this [__] since 2018 yeah like
I'm like like I don't know like it's
what we do with our time nature follows
patter how could how could I help me
understand how could a pattern predict
Facebook's going to buy Instagram Mark
Zuckerberg at I'm trying to think what
he did before he bought Instagram that
tipped me off to it well he has to yeah
but that's revisional history like at
the time like it was just like you know
at the time what I knew was that Mark
was looking at all things that had
attention not just Facebook did he tried
to buy maybe he tried to buy Twitter I
think that's it I think Mark tried to
buy Twitter I just could see by his
patterns that he got the two
entrepreneurs that I most pegged were
Bezos and Zuck because they I just
understood what they were doing Bezos
was doing how I built my dad's store
customer over everything I cared about
nothing I cared about my employees only
because I knew that would help me care
about my customers and I could give a
[__] about about anything else profit
margin what me whatever me and my dad
made I knew that if I was obsessed with
it's what I do now yeah like people
people make fun of me all I'm writing a
new book called day trading attention
it's GNA come out next year Vinnie I
swear to God I'm putting out literally
every secrit I'm this Tik Tok thing
right now like my friends make fun of me
of doing [__] like this like why are you
telling them it's back to the blue ocean
I'm like cuz I'm going to get mine M and
honestly I like I like that somebody's
going to email me in nine months it's
going to say steo podcast I'm going
clicking reading like yo never heard of
you actually I did see you actually I
thought you were a dick face before you
were on steveo's podcast like I saw you
say something I didn't like it I
listened I liked it it was a cool show
and then I heard the Tik Tok thing and I
started selling my [__] skateboards
on it and like oh my God I have 600 like
it's [__] awesome for me I people
aren't motivated so even if you give
them an idea they're not going to use it
not everyone not but but like to your
point as long as one person yeah to me
it's like I'm with you brother I'm with
you so much comma you weren't until you
were
I always was
respect but I was trying to follow your
story where you said that like you
started to build more momentum so maybe
well I always had the drive and I always
was like I will work for free for the
next 50 years to make it this this is
why you and I get along like work look
like work ethic matters to your point
everybody's trying to figure out a way
to make work ethic not part of it it
will always be part of it my point is
well then do something you love when
stebo said this and and Tracy
yeah said you're not going to make it I
get it Tracy didn't have the
understanding that the genre of
entertainment he was doing was about to
pop we grew up in an era where a lot of
our friends were amazing at video games
on Nintendo and Atari and television and
Sega Genesis but none of us were like
hey bro keep at it you might be the
[__] Tony Hawk of video games in 20
we didn't think that way like that I
didn't see yeah I didn't see that
because I wasn't thinking that way today
I see all those things like so what
happened was to his point I'm very good
at pattern recognition I'm very good at
popular culture history you know what's
funny I had dinner with Tommy Mata the
other night and he was telling me about
his career and I was like oh I see what
he did he knew what happened in the 50s
and 60s Frank Sinatra did A Christmas
album let me tell Mariah Carey to do it
because it makes sense Christmas out you
just keep playing you keep playing them
you keep playing them right like this
time of year like and he just did he did
Selen Deion's residency at Vegas yeah of
course he did that's what the [__]
rap pack did in the 60s he was good at
rebooting [__] I'm good rebooting [__]
when I see twitch I'm or when I see
social media I'm like yeah that was MTV
when MTV first came out I was like [__]
what the [__] is cable there's three
channels but HBO was fledging MTV was
play you know like MTV actually worked
right out the gate but what MTV was in
the 80s and 90s is what Tik Tok is now
it's just the place where kids attention
is everything is going to be player one
ready I can't wait that's what it'll be
like right I digital currency people are
going to be in their headsets I think I
think I think VR is real
it to be yeah it's going to be 20 years
but it's real like if I if I want to sit
into a therapist office but she's in New
York I'm going to get on the VR and
session like I mean that's you're pretty
much already there you just took the
[__] words out of my mouth perfect
job good work yeah cuz they're gateways
Zoom is the middle step to that yeah I
mean you could put on an Oculus right
now go to zoom.com and yeah the only
problem is one day the Oculus will look
like this and you're just like hello
you're reading AR like even better one
day Oculus is going to look like this
like a contact yeah like you seen the
movie Aon noten I know the punch line I
mean you're walking down the street and
it's just like a digital profile
everybody walks by it's AR is amazing AR
is [__] amazing by the way the new
Rayband meta Facebook thing oh or you
could just hit the uh dude it's [__]
fresh the fact that they did that from
one year to the next year and you don't
need earpods it's going to speed up I
love when people think that the moment
they're living in is when technology
stops no no I'll go this iPhone is going
to look like a [__] beeper in 20
years for sure yeah well it's going to
be the once neurolink takes off if it
does like that's going to be a game
changer but I it's it would be weird to
implant a chip into your brain I would
do it would you let me tell you when I
would do it I would do it I'm a second
wave guy I wouldn't be the first first
dude to do it because I like what's up
with the cancer but if you gave me a few
minutes of it and I understood I'm
definitely not going to be the hold out
like I'm going to like why not yeah like
I don't know like what do you chip in
your brain that's kind of weird concept
I get it but like people put [__] in
their heart and that was a weird concept
to people 70 years ago when people were
like yo we can fix everyone was dying of
heart attacks back in the day and then
they're like we're going to cut you open
and put a [__] thing on your heart I
would have been like [__] you yeah
Amazon when you could pay with your palm
at first I was like [__] that saw that
for the first time
yesterday I want everyone to know
everything I want everything to be
frictionless I was like of course
blockchain wait to deep fake videos come
out do you understand that we just did a
full pledge interview and in four years
kids are going to [__] around and change
the [__] we said on this and it's going
to look like we said it well have you
seen the on Tik Tok they're taking
aren't they already doing that they're
doing that with Rogan podcast they're
like hey my dick got bigger it's like
him and but they're changing his voice
to sell their product that's right so
what happened is the last 100 years
video has been I would argue video has
been the judge and jury of our society
if you see it on video happened JFK did
get assassinate like video was the proof
we're about to go into the era of where
you don't believe a single video over
the next decade all the videos we're not
going to see and then people going to
understand why the blockchain matters
because this episode in a three years
you're not going to post on YouTube
first you're going to post on your
blockchain address first IO that's right
to show that this was real and then go
up and then when I find on the internet
I don't know if this doesn't exist yet
from my knowledge base they're going to
connect those two things the
blockchain's about to get uncomfortably
uncomfortably important cardono baby all
the way to the Moon do you see what the
that's the for what the what the
blockchain does is nobody owns the
service everyone everyone's like America
China Russia everyone's like Facebook
Tik Tok all controlled now good good
news there's something called the
blockchain nobody controls the servers
that's the place of Truth and obviously
the nft craziness of two summers ago
that happened just like internet stocks
in in the first wave people got crazy
because this new thing things get
overvalued because greed and
Ridiculousness takes over it gets
reconnected corrected excuse me and then
you start to build the aftermath of the
2000 stock crash of all the internet
companies was 99% of the husters went
away and went back to Banking and being
a lawyer and the 1% that actually gave a
[__] built the Amazon and the paypals
and the ebays and the [__] that [__]
actually mattered but here's the pattern
how I know blockchain is going to pop
off is when you start seeing sign that
says we are no longer a cashless cash
business that's right you're like well
what is it it's like oh they want you on
your phone well it's so funny a buddy of
mine was like really passionate like a
year and a half ago when this combo was
hot he's going to get me at dinner and
he goes into he would [__] I felt
like he did a lot of a lot of HK I was
proud of him like some good points he
goes how could you trust it like how do
you know that's your cash how can you
trust it you have to hold it and I was
like I was like what's in your pocket
he's like what and he like so I got his
wallet out I go that's a credit card how
do you trust that I'm like do you
understand this the same conversation
that happened in 1960 when people were
talking about credit cards are coming
and all these could you imagine dudes in
the 60s all those characters with real
money like [__] you it's all cash I
don't want people knowing my [__] cash
cash cash I mean there's still people
like that today of course but but today
like it's I laugh when people like well
how do you know where your money is I'm
like where's your money right now yeah
where the [__] your money right now
losing 7% under your mattress a year
crazy yeah [__] t- bills now like
it's crazy like it's a it's listen all
this shit's
interesting first of all I just want to
say not that I'm wrapping it up I still
got time
but I'm enjoying the [__] out of this
but yeah I I I got to pee like crazy and
uh we crush it we've been doing it for a
while I know we got an hour and a half
oh we [__] annihilated I think this
is good that's a lot to ask of the
audience if you went Coast to Coast I
[__] love you dude I say that at the
end of every episode I say it's our
street team by the way Tik Tok live I'm
telling you right now here's why first
of all Let Me Tell let me I'm just going
to add a little more value Instagram
live you go on Instagram pings the
people that follow you they all come on
and then as I'm sure you know it
decreases over time right because
everyone comes they get pinged and and
they decrease makes sense like an email
like fine they see what's going on okay
I've seen yeah they hang for as long as
they can and they got a bounce but
because you had a full flood and it
declines Tik Tok goes the other way Tik
Tok the longer you're on the more
they're s surfacing your live even
non-followers too right especially
non-followers yeah Instagram doesn't
even do that Instagram doesn't do
non-followers so so you go on for an
hour you guys do what you got to I mean
this is the last thing you guys have to
worry about yeah it's all going to be
predicated on good ideas fun ways to do
it you have unlimited ways everything
from just wanting to do it by yourself
for an hour and talk about it to like
you producing cool ideas I don't have
any worry about that but you do it a lot
here's the best part also then you get
to chop up little pieces from it where
there's Tik Tok will show you where the
spikes were of interest you clip it and
you run those as Tik Tok and Instagram
and Facebook and YouTube short ads to
sell the stuff so you're basically
creating a production day to create good
ads while you're selling [__] on a Tik
Tok live it's crazy it's [__] crazy
you're basically let me use it in old
school terms you're basically doing a
QVC show that's randomly showing up to
people who don't know who you are and
for that you get to see the data that
shows you what commercials you should
make for your product on all the other
platforms that's great wow that's great
are you are you still on the same tip as
uh um posting as much as you can all day
every day yeah I think I think this like
push-ups if you do 30 push-ups you get
30 push-up results yeah you do 100
push-ups you get 100 now what people
don't hear when I say it back to things
I say that maybe I need to do a better
job job breaking down which is why I'm
writing this book or I or I'm hoping
people can hear what I'm saying when I
say post 30 times a day I'm also saying
post on seven platforms yes and I'm also
saying tweak it slightly based on a
platform so for example I think y'all
should post a lot more on
LinkedIn that doesn't seem native or
natural but meanwhile LinkedIn is
getting a ton of organic reach and
because most of it is business content
but people are in it all day long now
like Facebook anything that's somewhat
out of the ordinary does even better
and let's call spade a spade a lot of
people in LinkedIn are in their 40s and
50s who are like real fans of you it's
like a good demo for you wow so like so
all of a sudden think about 30 now 30
posts a day all of a sudden if you're
just posting on Instagram and YouTube
that's like 30 a day that's [__] up
but when you're posting on are you guys
posting on Snapchat
Spotlight there you go I know trust me I
know I'm watching everything Snapchat's
got unbelievable reach if you know what
you're doing YouTube shorts versus is
just YouTube LinkedIn is now if you say
when you know what you're doing like are
there different strategies for like
different from Snapchat content strategy
is the hardest marketing craft in the
world YouTube shorts is where it's at G
media yeah but that's super expensive
and for big companies that's why I'm
trying to put out as much that's why
every five or 10 I wrote a book about 10
years ago called jab jab jab right hook
and to this day I get 10 emails a day
like head of marketing this marketing
that entrepreneur like that book and I I
went like a huge rally of it a couple
months ago just randomly just hearing
from a lot of people of how much that
book changed her life and I was like man
how are and then even new people like I
just read it it's so great I'm like [__]
man it's so outdated so I started
writing a new book called jab jab jab
left hook oh great but then when I went
through it I realized this is much more
complex so it's it's been renamed to day
trading attention because that's what I
do I day trade attention I'm giving you
platform strategy right now but I'm also
paying attention to everything that's
happening in pop culture why are people
wearing corduroy hats why did Alex Earl
pop on Tik Tok why did liquid death work
who's the upand cominging rapper what
food is working like shoes sneakers like
why like I like why did vans cross over
from skateboard West Coast kids to black
kids in the urban world like why why why
why so I live in that both on platform
and on culture once you understand those
things you can
dominate okay wow all right let let's
dominate yeah I love it dude thank you
man thank you for having oh yeah that
was that was
rad